hey so your heading is client-server
architecture client architecture that
sounds really big and techie and
complicated but it's really not as hard
to understand as it sounds and in fact
all of you I would argue are using the
client-server architecture right now
okay so what does it mean and how does
it have an effect on us and how we use
networks today okay well let's take a
step back first and let's let me
introduce two different terms which I
that you probably had before at least
one of them and I want to distinguish
between them so let's have a think about
this and land and or when head strange I
can use but let's go over them now Al
and I think most of you know what Al and
is or at least what it stands for it's
an acronym which stands for local what's
the a stable area and then the end of
course we're in communications systems
so the N stands for network okay a local
area network now you can probably guess
we're seeing is I'm distinguishing
between these two I'm trying to put them
aside each other but a on the add of
where stand for the same thing they
stand for area and for network but being
that they're two separate ideas they're
actually in contrast to each other what
do you think the W might stand for
instead of local what might the opposite
of local be yeah sorry sorry worldwide
well it's not that bad actually because
the W stands for wide not necessarily
worldwide but why in that it's it's not
just in your little area which is what
local means right and someone says ah
can you go to the local shops they mean
the shops that you're closest to right
and why it means it's over a larger sort
of area that's what we're talking about
okay so what's the distinction between
these two the first thing you should
know is that I've been a bit sneaky here
and said that there's like a big solid
line between
lands and the words there's not it's
sort of more like a wavy sort of shady
load okay because it's not necessarily
easy to look at a network particularly
one which is sort of medium in size and
say it's this one or it's that one okay
but this is still a helpful distinction
nonetheless even if um it's closer to a
spectrum that it is to black one okay so
let's distinguish between them what we
say local usually what we're referring
to is usually within a building or a
site building or a site so a building
would be something like say Cameron
block right or maybe your house that's a
building what I mean by site is that
sometimes for example in our school
right you might have several buildings
but really they're they comprise a unity
okay so we would say that James ruse has
a lab which is comprised of multiple
buildings but it's all one site okay and
I think that's still a justifiable local
area network okay now again it's like
how do I know which one it is as I go to
the next one you might be able to
distinguish it a little easier well we
say a wide area network we're usually
thinking about geographically wide okay
geographically one so we're talking
about say something over the size of a
suburb okay or maybe a state or a
country or these days now the globe
right the entire world okay
I think the key idea that distinguishes
these two is that when you look at a
building recite so I said your house or
on the school okay
all the people using this local area
network have strong bonds apart from the
network does that make sense so everyone
at the school like students and teachers
if I took away the land you would still
be related to each other yes you're
still in classes together I still teach
you I still see the playground and so on
okay but when it comes to a wide area
network if you take away such a network
like say the
the public telephone network or the
Internet
okay there are people who are are
accessible through this network who you
might actually have no relationship with
if I remove this network does that make
sense so here there's a people who use
this network tend to be unified already
whereas people who use this network I
unified by virtue of the network okay
and they weren't unified it anyway
before okay so that's a helpful way to
distinguish rather than like you know is
this like or three kilometers radius or
four kilometers radius it's not like a
nice concrete number okay it's more
about purpose and functionality okay now
speaking of purpose or functionality why
do people usually have a local area
network being that the people here
already have relationships with each
other they already work together that
kind of thing what reasons you should
suggest you can think of you know our
school why do we have a local area
network now I don't need a network to
talk to people because I just you know
say hi why would we do this yeah ah good
okay so shared let's let's go with
access and sharing um now there's a
phrase here we learnt it a couple of
days ago right what kinds of things do
we want people in this network to access
and share yeah perfect exactly where
network resources so you know um
Ricky's example was the Internet okay so
that's a modem you've got really just
one internet connection going outside
the school but we want everyone in this
space to be able to access it okay so we
put a network in place that allows you
guys to hook into it okay
by the same token printers or hard
drives and so on we talked about this at
length before okay so network resources
don't forget that all Soviet software
and data as well okay now when you think
about wide area networks what is the
purpose of a wide area network usually
for example a suburb or state you don't
have people sharing a printer you know
I'm just going to set this to my printer
that's is epic I'll be right back guys
um
but usually about sharing resources
what's the purpose for wide area network
maybe I should ask earlier question well
what are some examples of wide area
Newark's I've already given you two to
be tabled okay so for example be
internet give you an online maybe NOLA
one what you reach for every time you
sorry yep that's the telephone network
okay so now let's think about both of
these okay let's think about both of
them particularly the phone one because
it's a little clearer okay the phone
network is not about sharing resources
at all is it what is the few had to
describe it in a sentence what's the
purpose of the phone network why we
install phones these react what you
reckon so again latter okay good now so
this is getting it the purpose of a wide
area where I think this is correct I
think your track is right that the
purpose of a wine area dealer because
what was always communication well hold
on a second
isn't a local area narrow also
communicated what's the difference
what's the difference - distant
okay so number one we're talking about
the difference of scale
I think but number two if you remember
back a few lessons to when we had that
on that Venn diagram which did look like
a Venn diagram it just look like a look
like a seashell actually but anyway but
we distinguish between systems that
communicate but they communicate because
they have to right we put that traffic
lights and they communicate because
there's no other way to achieve their
purpose except they have to communicate
okay as opposed to systems that were
specifically designed for communicating
and if you can't communicate you might
as well not have the system at all okay
so here I suppose we would say the
explicit purpose of a wide area network
is explicit communication okay I just
want to talk to someone
right and they might be very very far
away so therefore I introduce a system
which lets me do that okay whereas a
local area network is more about well I
want to be able to get to this stuff and
the easiest way I can do that is to
introduce communications links okay
rather than for instance getting every
single computer and every single laptop
in the school and giving it a wireless
you know dongle for it's already
internet connection tremendously
inefficient way to do it okay much
better to use a communication system
like this okay